c'est la première fois de sa vie qui
vient à paris on a compris maintenant
ils arrivent à gare du nord
il appelle un taxi prend le taxi ils
rendent en taxi si je vous dépose ou
montparnasse niva et pendant tout le
trajet hills ou le taxi avec des
questions et la tour eiffel c'est
comment et les filles comment elles sont
aidées par isaïe lui plaît de taxi l'on
peut que toi mais le calcule pas trop et
un moment donné aux taxis
excusez moi le petit roux gravé au bout
de la voiture que c'est quoi mais
qu'avez mercedes ils voient que c'est un
10 as et un viseur c'est un mec qui
m'énerve dans la rue je visais je les
classe et dit regarde par exemple cette
vieille dame
il faut aussi fausse le mec rotax il
faut aussi une femme arrive à laver
d'amis tous ne l'entend pas les mecs des
douze mois j'ai ouvert la porte ils
auraient raté ses deux mecs ils ont
grandi ensemble ils sont des toiles est
bègue le budget ils ont grandi ensemble
maintenant les deux tu vois le primaire
ensemble que les gens semblent ici
ensemble n'arrive à la fac chacun fait
sa vie trois ans après se raconte dans
la rue
le premier duo bernard coco tu m'as dit
ben je vais très bien trop mais six
tubes et de bbb à bbb crise non pas
c'est fini ça c'est l'ancien taux et des
mémés coq encore
deux jours va pas relancer la publicité
et du bac où j'ai été voir un marabout
mame dr quant à lui dit non j'étais voir
un marabout l'adresse du marabout ultime
attaque est passé pour moi ma part je
peux jouer quatre heures tapas de force
et dit d'accord je dire aux taxis où tu
m'as tu vu
il y va le mec qui sonne bonjour oui je
sais pourquoi vous êtes là haut
prévu à lui-même est entré alors il
rentre dans une chambre noire
il ya il entend juste une voix qui dit à
avancer il avance allait dans la
deuxième pièce dit mais mais mais mais
mais mais oh mais qui qui qui qui me
parle là est bien avancée et déshabillez
vous dites oh je peux pas en faire quand
même dit déshabillez vous il se
déshabille monde aisé que j'ai pensé
vous en à mario sessa ça sent pas bon
exécuter ou si vous voulez parler
en l'espèce il se baisse le climat
concombres dans le média du revenu
demain pour la lettre b
c'est le couple présidentiel oui mais
c'est mon chrono macro is au maroc qui
se balade ils ont besoin de souffler un
peu tu as compris l'année qu'ils ont eue
c'est vrai et donc justement sur un
génie long qui frôle le génie sort elie
vous avez le droit veut c'est d'écouter
au génie j'ai prise dans la république
d'avoir des problèmes avec ses blagues
voie publique j'aimerais bien comme mes
parents m'ont toujours parlé de mon
arrière arrière grand mère j'aimerais
bien l'avoir à dire non on peut pas
faire un choix et j'ai dit je peux pas
faire revivre léman choisi un autre j'ai
un autre mode veut aider ben écoute et
j'aimerais que chez moi en france et
plus de gilet jaune et plus de problèmes
que tout le monde y même et des bords
elle est enterrée ou ton arrière grand
mère
c'est un petit garçon voilà c'est un
petit garçon sa mère lui dit va nous
acheter de la confiture pénurie coin
fois dans le quartier il y va y rentre
chez l'épicier dit écoute maman et a dit
dans lui de la conviction dit ça tombe
bien je ne confiture qui vient d'arriver
des états unis le petit prend la
confiture c'est et rentrer chez lui mais
sur le chemin d'irène aux états unis il
faut que je bouge alors les nouveaux le
truc il a goûté arrive pas parler il
arrive chez sa mère du joueur mais c'est
pas possible d'un mois le pot être le
policier l'enfer c'est fou ça quand je
le paye sort bien c'est quoi ce bordel
la confiture visa le père il prend le
pouls du jeu pas possible cette famille
folle c'est pas possible et par énerver
chez l'épicier ou avec une pièce qui va
pas j'en ai à [ __ ]
c'était pas content vokoun sa roquette
sur le chemin et que je n'ai pas le
chemin par le commissaire il croise un
mec
excusez moi le comesa j'ai dû manger
impôts elodie levé ps
[Applaudissements]
il attendait ces gens mariés mais
laurence ses danses ses personnages il
l'a très mal racontée est exceptionnel
ça fait deux mois que sa prépa